[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ne cherchez pas dans les pianos ce qu'il
n'y a pas soyez heureux d'avoir l'écho
du temps de papa palse espagnol des
années folles ou bien sardane que l'on
dansait àtit pas après le repas ne
cherchez pas dans les couloirs de mes
châteaux ce qu'il peut y avoir à
l'intérieur de mes pianos vous luy
trouveriez le plus souvent que la
chanson du vent du vent d'automne mon
seul ami d'arè
avant ne cherchez pas dans les armoires
qui vous font
pe le profil noir d'un vieux fondôme aux
yeux rieur l'on volage n'est plus que
nuage qui se tortillle avec douceur sur
les toil trains à vapeur ne cherchez pas
sur le canal de la Robine le Clair fanal
d'une péniche qui se
débine ne cherchez pas au pont d'Arcole
les murs de la vieille école elle est
devenue garage rbus pour
autobus
ne cherchez pas sur les rivages de C la
mer les premiers pas que vous faisiez
devant la
mer contre la
drague clapote les vagues mais plus
jamais ne vous effare quand vous vous
promenez près des phares et puis revenez
dans le présent pour un séjour à Île de
France vous avez une île d'amour
puisqu'on vous aime en ce coinl alors ne
cherchez pas ne cherchez pas dans les
pianos ce qu'il n'y a
[Musique]
pas puisqu'on vous aime en ce coin là
alors ne cherchez pas ne cherchez pas
dans les pianos ce qu' n'y a pas ne
cherchez pas dans les pianos ce qui
[Applaudissements]